joining us now for reaction in Raleigh
North Carolina is Saul Eisenberg who was
the number two attorney on the Bill
Clinton whitewater investigation and in
Washington Democratic strategist Richard
Goodstein all right Saul let's start
with you I had fairly harsh words
tonight after we learned more about a
Jeannie Reed and her association her
past association with Ben Rhodes
personal attorney for Rhodes
representing him in the contacts with
the House Intel committee obviously
Andrew Weissman Peters struck the list
seems to go on and on every day we learn
more what's your take well I don't
believe Muller should resign I don't
think there's a case for him resigning
yet but I'm very concerned about the
struck situation he never should have
been picked to be the FBI lead agent on
that investigation because number one as
you pointed out there's a conflict of
interest since he was the lead agent
working on the Hillary email
investigation and don't forget this he's
a witness now to Laura there is an I G's
investigation of the Hillary email
server investigation and there are
congressional investigations color is
supposed to be we're gonna play this
montage in a moment for Richard as well
it was of this guy of unassailable
character oh he is he's the best of the
best to do this investigation we have
three ranked partisans working on this
investigation ari Weissman and struck
it's not that they're just Democrats
that's fine but they were actively
working for political opponents of
President Trump and apparently there's
no there's no issue with Muller to
actually reveal this to the public we
have to find it out it's working
how do you know that struck was working
for his opponents I've got a real
problem with struck being on the case
because the conflicts of interest I have
a real problem I just I just heard the
stuff today about misery and I'm blown
away by that and I think that's very
disturbing because struck was sending
texts to his I guess mistress back
during the debate so also worked on the
investigation we understand and yeah but
I was really dumb right but you know but
you know what yeah I know yeah good
sorry go ahead
no let me just here's the problem this
is not a run-of-the-mill investigation
Richard I want you to get on this it's
not the run of a mill allegation don't
be exasperated Richard you get plenty of
time I've known you forever I never get
shortchanged
ah this has to be an unassailable team
this could not be a team of political
adversaries of the president that
doesn't sit well with people and it cast
doubt on the integrity of this
investigation the appearance of a
political conflict of interest Richard
your response yeah this is not James
Carville running this investigation
Bob Moeller was picked by Reagan Bush
won and Bush too for very important
federal law enforcement positions right
Andrew Weissman took on the Genovese and
Gambino and Comino families and the
Enron prosecution this is the kind of
guy we want and incidentally if you and
people watching here think that Donald
Trump did nothing wrong this is exactly
the kind of team headed by mower that
you should want to stay there and as far
this this gee Neary instantly I worked
at Wilmer Cutler some time ago I don't
happen not to know them I left before
they were there look if we're going to
somehow impute to every lawyer what
their client may or may not have did
look again Ben Rhodes would be
interviewed by the house okay unless
every lawyer Laura with hired by Muller
work for the Federalist Society I doubt
you'd be happy now
I doubt it that's not what we're talking
about you can jump in here these are
jumping different so listen Barney Oh
Gorsuch made contributions to the
Republican National Committee made
contributions to Republican candidates
so somehow one at a time this is this is
how it would go down if the shoe were on
the other foot if we had a fact pattern
involving a Democrat being investigated
Hilary Clinton on the email server with
a Republican with these types of text
messages and representations the left
would be raising holy hell about it and
I would say maybe for good reason
because you cannot have a big special
prosecution as we're seeing right now
with a gaggle of partisans who are
adversaries working whether for the
Clinton Foundation who's working for Ben
Rhodes working for all these different
immediately he was removed immediately
as for the case for Weitzman you haven't
made a case for Weissman listen being
unqualified okay having a conflict of
interest is aligned everything is
significant the wrong thing is extremely
significant and Muller should have known
better and he should have known better
not the guy have this guy head of the
investigation go ahead oh sorry
by two to one the American public thinks
Donald Trump is dishonest not as
reckless and not stable so if there
happens to be somebody who works for
Muller who shares the view that Donald
Trump's not a peachy guy guess what he's
like two-thirds of the public
yeah and it's rich excuse me it's rich I
don't have a problem with it one second
it is a problem with that it's rare so
listen to me
it's rich when James Comey broke the
rules to have its July 5th press
conference attacking Hillary by issuing
the jewel the October 28th letter and
did nothing to enforce all here one more
point cuz we're running way over so
here's the problem that's not an issue
but point is the guys wait a second I
thought it was my turn now let me sum up
the people who had the people on the
left in the media who were complaining
that Muller is being unfairly attacked
should look in the mirror because you
mentioned James Carville
Carville he set the playbook he said and
I quote Ken Starr is one mistake away
from having his kneecaps busted and that
was a man who was regularly invited to
the White House so I don't like all this
stuff that's happening to Muller
I don't think Moses had resigned but
they're taking the Clinton playbook
tomorrow and let me tell you it's coming
back to bite them all right guys there's
a lot more to say on this but
unfortunately we're way over thank you
both for joining us Richard and saw